carpentry was his hobby Phillip Azam
gira made it his profession when he
couldn't find a job as a mechanic
because renting a workshop is too
expensive he works at a roadside in a
suburb of Nairobi wooden tools are
costly in Kenya as an gira used to new
customers willing to pay in advance
before you could produce anything now he
uses the mobile credit service in SH
woori am choueiri it's a good experience
like for small businesses where you you
don't have to go to the bank they give
you money directly then you paid but an
attractive offer for Kenyans with little
income and easy to handle all you need
is a phone so whenever Phillip bazan
gira has some earnings he stops at a
neighborhood branch of his mobile
provider as soon as he deposit some
money he can borrow up to double that
amount the money's debited through his
mobile phone accountant sake
when I'm paying back my lawn I need to
pay with an extra mount so that where
the extra mount is taken from after you
pay alone they just take the loan amount
and then the extra amount is sent back
to our account the interest rate on the
loan is seven percent for small
businesses it's the only way to get
loans banks judge even higher rates with
a mobile credit system Philip as in giro
doesn't have to wait until customers pay
up before you can buy more timber mobile
phone operators safaricom introduced
them to re credit service three years
ago it now has 10 million customers the
average loan size that is dispersed to
these talk customers on em choueiri is
in the region of 1700 to two thousand
shillings wearing their micro news two
thousand shillings is about 18 euros for
years Kenya's banks ignored the
microloan sector until mobile phone
operators proved that it can be very
profitable their competitors are now
trying to set up rival Michael own
systems this could mean cheaper loans
for Kenya which could boost economic
growth if I can make that loan to you
over the phone very low transaction
costs suddenly I've got a different
dynamic so we've had this we've had this
as a renaissance of credit that has come
through the mobile phone and it's I
think people still have not properly
estimated its value and the boost its
giving the economy today Philip basm
gira is one of 10 million insh woori
users in Kenya many of his friends and
family members in rural areas also use
the service it is becoming essential for
people on low incomes